hey drew hi nichelle
so drew do you have any holiday plans
with the family this year you know no
big plans just happy to be with my
kids which is just everything in my
universe okay we know you've got some
really big things coming up on the drew
barrymore show next week wednesday's
episode will be really special because
your audience will be filled with nurses
i love that tell us about it well the
entire hour
is about them and it's just a very
personal show for everyone involved it
has so much heart and meaning and nurses
are our superheroes now they truly are
and that's why together with the drew
barrymore show we teamed up with johnson
and johnson to honor nurses here's a
sneak peek at drew's show nurses are the
ultimate druid
lifting nurses up lifts us all up and
today
is for you
and because of you things get emotional
when drew gives two special nurses
making significant impacts in their
health care systems a surprise thank you
so much
thank you for coming today johnson
johnson has been such a supporter of
nurses for the last 125 years
and it's because
we see their ability to empower
themselves and each other to be able to
educate people and when you think about
superheroes that's what superheroes do
[Music]